as the nation watches nevada's still
accounting ballots clark county
announced just a short time ago
it will start to release new vote totals
twice a day and that will start today
we have hector mejia live outside
election headquarters with the latest
there hi hector
hey there alex good afternoon and the
big question is how much is actually
left to
count this morning clark county released
results for
30 000 votes and we'll get more results
later on today
and here's the latest when it comes to
clark county's outstanding ballots in
the race for the white house
there are 63 thousand melon ballots left
to count
those will get into the system over the
next few days and the goal is to get
them in the system by sunday
on top of that there are about 60
thousand other ballots provisional
ballots to sort
but not all of those will get through
the elections department has been
under scrutiny for taking this long to
count mail ballots
and here's the response from registrar
of voters joe gloria who said
as many as 300 election workers are
tabulating results
the process is very deliberate in the
way we process here so through the
agilis which is our
mail ballot processing system that's the
first step
that agilis machine will verify
signatures
and then those that aren't verified as a
match that has to go to a
manual physical process and there are
two steps in that process
that was just part of the process
according to gloria who says there's
more
a reminder that today at 5 pm is the
deadline for those who were contacted to
bring in their id
that's for same-day registration voters
and those who registered online
and for those who have to cure their
ballot there's a hotline set up you can
call for help the number is 702-455-6552
i called earlier and there's only a
two-minute wait
time that's for voters who did not sign
or whose signature did not match any of
the signatures on record and back out
here live
there's so much interest we have media
outlets from around the planet we're
talking about outlets from the middle
east
japan and from europe and of course our
national partners here tracking election
results here in our own state as clark
county continues counting
mail ballots inside now as far as the
ballots that are left to count we're
told that the majority of the
outstanding ballots
should be in the system by sunday so
hopefully before the weekend is over
we'll get to know
likely who will take the hotly contested
six electoral votes here in nevada
reporting live outside clark county
election headquarters hector mejia
8 news now